why did we choose this life why did we
become superheroes we dedicate our lives
to fighting crime for one reason to make
a billion dollars on a superhero
franchise now let's go through the plan
one more time
first we start with a [ __ ] movie then we
do the super Craig movie then super
Craig and kun will join forces in the
human kite movie just as we start
ramping up Kenny's Netflix series how
come I have to have the Netflix series I
want a movie - you have a movie
mysterion you're in the third [ __ ] and
friends united movie after your Netflix
series
yeah but he's saying he doesn't ever get
his own movie do I get my own movie not
everyone gets their own movie but
franchise claim sucks if we want to make
billions of dollars and they think we
should start with a tupperware movie
right start with a black superhero
Marvel is making a black superhero movie
yet now they waited years to get to that
we follow their plan we do all the real
people first and we sneak the black guy
in at phase three how about we just do
movies starring all of us like all the
time but then we're just rehashing the
same old material there's nothing wrong
with doing the exact same movie to start
a franchise okay JJ Abrams okay okay so
you're on Carmen's side he just likes
this plan because he gets two movies a
face one guy we have to just go with
this plan we don't even have one movie
yet how did it get to this how did we
grow so far apart
you go with the plan baby we'll just go
and do our own franchise yeah yeah oh
you want subawardees how would you watch
yeah dude Civil War you you get on my
house will make way more money on our
franchise
go ahead of that you don't you get
halfway through phase 1 on your
franchise ZZ comics I thought Civil War
wasn't supposed to happen until phase 3
shut up super Kraig
I didn't want to have to do this when
you leave me no choice did I just hear
someone use a microaggression available
December 6th get the stick of truth free
with purchase pre-order now for Towelie
bonus content